to these protesters it's clear what the
alternative for Germany party stands
for Nazis get out they shout on the
other side of the fence leaders of the
afd are campaigning for Parliament seats
in
Bavaria our most important point is that
we want to stop migration we want push
back centers at Germany's borders and we
want to stop giving cash money to
refugees and reject all illegal
immigrants Al show the afd could become
the second largest party in Bavaria
listening to the campaign it sounds like
Germany has only one problem and that is
migration and the arrival of refugees
but limiting the number of Asylum
Seekers is not only a popular theme for
the far right other parties are
campaigning on it as well yet economists
say that Germany needs nearly half a
million foreign workers to keep its
economy going and that's a message that
politicians here seem to
avoid bavaria's prime minister marus
zder of the largest party the
conservative ative CSU wants migration
to be kept while facing strong
competition the CSU is expected to win
this
election we say yes to helping people
but we urge our Chancellor in Berlin to
have a clear plan and stop
uncontrollable
migration at a Reception Center in
Munich these refugees from Sierra Leon
have been traveling for months through
dozens of countries they tell us that
Germany is their best hope for
protection Bavaria has registered more
than 30,000 Asylum Seekers this year an
increase of nearly 80% on 2022 but
that's less than half the number of
refugees who arrived in 2015
municipalities have been struggling to
house them and new shelters like this
one near Munich are being built
sometimes against the will of local
residents moment the focus is always on
refugees refugees and refugees for us
Germans not much has been done when you
look at the prices normal work like us
can hardly afford our groceries any
longer nor pay our rent a sentiment
often hurt during this election campaign
yeah it scares me we have come here
because we don't have any opportunities
at home we work hard to contribute and
we should overcome any divisions
together extremism does not help Germany
others are concerned as well ahead of
the vote more than 30,000 people took to
the streets in Munich to protest against
the rise of the right soon will know
what the response of nearly 10 million
Bavarian voters will be step fast in Al
jazer Munich